قد يكون فيسبوك مدينًا لك بالمال، وقد
وافقت الشركة الأم في ديسمبر على دفع
725 مليون دولار للمستخدمين بسبب
مزاعم بأنها شاركت بياناتهم،
وتزعم الدعوى الجماعية أن
فيسبوك يسمح لأطراف ثالثة بالوصول إلى
بيانات المستخدم الخاصة التي ربما
تتضمن أعياد ميلاد الأشخاص ومسقط رأسهم
وحتى الرسائل الخاصة إذا  أنت أحد
مستخدمي Facebook في الولايات المتحدة لأي
فترة بين 24 مايو 2007 و
22 ديسمبر 2022، يمكنك تقديم مطالبة
ولكن عليك التصرف بسرعة. الموعد النهائي
لتقديم المطالبة هو 11:59 مساءً بتوقيت المحيط الهادئ في
25 أغسطس قبل أن أتمكن من الدخول  كم من
المال يمكنك الحصول عليه فعليًا، الرابط لتقديم
مطالبة موجود هنا، ويمكنك أيضًا العثور
عليه في قصة CNN، حيث يطلب
نموذج تقديم المطالبة
معلومات أساسية مثل عنوانك،
سواء كنت تقدم مطالبة تتعلق
بفيسبوك حالي  حسابك أو متى
قمت بحذفه منذ ذلك الحين، وكيف ترغب في
تلقي دفعة التسوية الخاصة بك،
يعتمد المبلغ الذي يمكن أن يُدفع لك على
ثلاثة عوامل، وعدد الأشخاص الذين يقدمون
مطالبات صالحة، ومدة بقائك
مستخدمًا نشطًا لفيسبوك خلال
فترة الأهلية ومع  سيكون إجمالي صافي
صندوق التسوية بعد
خصم التكاليف القانونية الإدارية والتكاليف الأخرى،
وليس هناك معرفة بالضبط متى
يمكن أن تحصل على الدفع، ومن المقرر أن يتم تحديد جلسة استماع
للموافقة على التسوية في الشهر المقبل، ولكن
الطعون المحتملة من أي من الجانبين قد
تؤخر الدفع